you're beautiful indeed in our series of
more perfect union we aim to show that
what unites us as Americans is really
far greater than what divides us an
estimated 20% of children and teenagers
in this country live with the skin
disease a children's house for the Soul
is an organization that helps kids
embrace these conditions national
correspondent Jericka Duncan shows us
how the nonprofit teamed up with a
fashion designer to help three Texas
teenagers feel confident well in their
own skin Jericka good morning to you
good morning to you Gayle literally that
is what happened the three girls we
spoke to each have a rare skin condition
that has affected their appearance well
through the nonprofit that seeks to help
people embrace their differences the
girls now say they are able to look in
the mirror and say I'm beautiful no
matter what 14-year old Alex schoener 13
year old Emily Haygood and 16 year old
Mia Johnson are at their final fitting
in Houston preparing for a fashion show
in New York City I'm a little nervous to
be honest
the dresses they'll be modeling in
represent something more than what meets
the eye
it's just so special it's really
something that you never think would
happen to you
each of these girls has a serious skin
condition and each one of their dress
patterns mirrors the image of what that
girl's condition looks like under a
microscope
I have alopecia areata which is an
autoimmune disease that causes my hair
to fall out and second grade I lost all
my hair but it all grew back and then in
around seventh and eighth grade I
started losing even more hair and that's
when I think I got really scared I was
like what if I go into high school bald
with no hair like what will people think
of me I have severe atopic dermatitis
like another word for eczema people
would ask me is it contagious is it
poison ivy and I just really lowered my
self-confidence
I have scleroderma on my face and it's
basically where I lose tissue and it
made me look insecure going into middle
school when people are trying to find
themselves
you know like find who you are Mia Alex
and Emily found each other through dr.
Elanna Brie's a children's house for the
Soul in Houston dr. Bria dermatologist
by trade left her high-paying job at a
hospital and later opened the nonprofit
four years ago I hope that what we do
brings a light to the world for the
darkness of these kids they suffer so
much and if we can just be a little
small light I think that's awesome
dr. Bri says her goal wasn't just to
treat what you can see but to treat the
emotional wounds that are not visible is
there a cure for any of your skin
conditions there's not a cure but mine
there's a possibility that we go away
when I'm older but I'm 13 and still have
a lot of time to get older so and mine
is inactive right now so doctors
recommend surgery and stuff but you know
because they want to fix you but I've
always denied it because part of who I
am most people I think when they are
diagnosed with a skin condition they
think that it's like probably the worst
thing that could ever happen to them is
that what you thought originally
originally I will be honest I was not
very happy with it and I was like why
did this happen to me but now my
perspective has definitely changed what
changed their perspective I think it was
the people around me and especially dr.
Bri and her team they really helped me
to view myself as a beautiful young
woman that I am today the moral to this
story
[Music]
it's that attitude that brought these
girls to this moment where all eyes were
on them for all the right reasons this
was a children's house first time that
it did a fashion show but it probably
won't be their last
they look putting on a dress and feeling
really pretty in it and they get to do
that obviously done jury